hey there guys so this summer
transformers age of extinction is going
to hit movie theaters Autobots rolling
out Decepticons do it or whatever they
do is it gonna be the Transformers movie
that we crave here with thoughts on that
Nick Monday you know what man ten years
ago when you talk to young Nick Mundy
who had a sparkle in his eye and you
said hey Michael Bay is gonna make a
Transformers movie I was excited what
happened what happened to that sparkle
Nick frankly after the last one I I
don't think I have it in me but I got
some ways I think we can finally make
transformers be the movie we deserve as
a race weight as a race as the human
race yes no oh not as no okay no every
everyone every race creed deserves a
good trend just wanted a class
thank you number one stop trying to be
funny it doesn't need to be funny yeah
we don't need this to be ghostbusters
it's a Transformers movie we didn't come
to laugh we came to see giant king
robots beat the [ __ ] out of each other
and remind us of the cartoon that we
loved as kids and the time that we were
happy the other problem with
transformers trying to be funny yes is
that a little racist
remember jazz from the first yeah
transformers this looks like oh cool
please and let us not forget
transformers 2 where we were introduced
to the hatchbacks mudflap and skids and
mudflap what are we gonna do with this
shrimp I'm not in the cartoon these
characters were fully fleshed out yet
all we have are just jive-talking robots
you know what I think that leads to your
next point doesn't it give the
Transformers some personality
now do me a favor describe a bumblebee
for me in more than one sentence yellow
just yellow see I got autistic robot who
can control the radio but that's it
it seems like other than Optimus Prime
and Megatron none of these robots have
any personality why should we give us
even Optimus all we get is just speeches
my name is Optimus Prime we are
autonomous robotic organisms from the
planet Cybertron our races united by a
history long forgotten but the day will
never come that we forsake this planet
[Music]
stop playing Nickelback I don't know we
did a title card
stop playing Nickelback's that's a rule
to just live by yeah general Nick what
do you got first next give the character
some personalities so you got nebbish
here oh yeah
whacky adults girl with hot ass and then
patriotic soldier yeah but so it looks
like they're scrubbing that template for
the new one yeah but now we have Boston
dad in Texas I think we just found the
transformer
okay so what kind of character would you
like to see in a Transformers film I'm
glad you asked I'm glad finally someone
asked Oh what about someone like Jeff
Goldblum and dress--i Park who is witty
and knowledgeable about science and
philosophy but also takes the threat
seriously or someone like Jeff Goldblum
in Independence Day always a bossing
yeah know someone who cares about
something passionately like the
environment but also can use that
knowledge you know to use it to cut the
aliens also I'd like to point out that
when you were talking about Jeff
Goldblum you started to sound a little
bit like him who is witty and
knowledgeable about science and
philosophy Nick what's your next point
okay don't hook up the Dinobots
that's my thing that's what I love
that's your that's my Dinobots are my
Dinobots alright alright they're not
even getting Top Billing this movie's
called transformers age of extinction
should be called transformers holy Sh
we're doing Dinobots hope to Christ it's
really good it's a long title yeah but
all those titles are really tough it's
like transformers darkside of the Fallen
of extinction none of it makes sense
what else have you got
show us the action the problem is they
use so many quick cuts and close-ups
that it feels like you're just watching
an epileptic seizure or an acid trip hey
some people may like Pacific Rim some
people may have not but at least they
had wide shots in the movies we got to
see them in wide shot glory beating the
spouts of each other the guys taking a
boat and using it as a base and it stays
on the shot for more than 10 seconds
Nick what's next no more love stories
this is transformers we don't need
flowers and hearts okay we lasers and
robots kicking each other on the balls
that's all we need you don't want the
hot sexual tension of a Shia LaBeouf and
a rosy Huntington Wheatley I don't know
what those words are I'll be honest I
just want I want to see a love story
between Transformers and America maybe
then maybe the bad guy is the English
the British crown coming back Great
Britain is one of our best allies until
they didn't realize like Decepticon
technology is taking over and corrupted
them you want it you want to see the OP
Optimus Prime rip Big Ben right out of
the ground yes okay next point give
someone else a shot I love but it's time
to move on from Transformers you've
already done four of them and we already
know what to expect
explosions hot girls American flags and
it's going to be over two and a half
hours long you could be spending your
time making bad boys three the rock to
pain and Game three I have scripts for
all of them they're all very great it's
time to move on man feel like Old Yeller
about to take Michael Bay into the hot
beach from the stingray corvette that we
just pulled up to and then take a
crossbow and put in his heart don't kill
Michael Bay I don't want you I love the
Transformers I love Michael Bay I really
want it to work and I think you take
these tips you take these ways to fix it
and I think you can make the movie that
we'll all love
it's got Mark Wahlberg it's got Dinobots
don't get up man we was like you want it
to be Pacific Rim meets Independence Day
oh yeah know that I should have just
said that yeah okay how to fix trade for
me yeah make it Pacific Rim meets
Independence Day what you can do is have
like a Goldblum character in Will Smith
and then they just fell down on my chair
and then okay I want to thank Nick Mundy
for being here guys are you excited for
transformers how you feeling about it
leave us an answer in the comment
section below
best answer is going to get a limited
edition sprint from the artist Kirk
tomaría called the Torrance's it's the
family from the shining how awesome is
that
and that print is courtesy of gallery
1988 check them out in the description
below
awesome pop culture stuff I want to
thank you guys for watching I want to
thank my good friend Nick Mundy thank
you for
of course I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter bye-bye
but King Joffrey is all like I don't
care mom I'm busy having the most
punchable face and King's Landing
that's what intelligent women do with
that toad Joffrey